los incendios en el sur de chile
continúan Arrasando todo a su paso los
vecinos de la comuna de walkie una zona
rural y aislada en la región sureña del
bío bío no olvidarán jamás este verano
austral en el que se han visto acosados
por las llamas
Juan agricultor uno de Los afectados en
el área de Chamizal pudo salvar su casa
y también todos sus animales solo perdí
un galpón y madera pero su tía que vive
al lado no corrió con la misma suerte
a ver el fuego como veníamos tuve que
evacuar y algunos quedaron acá que
después yo subí Por acá de una parrilla
Pues sí fui a dejar abajo a mi mamá al
pueblo que ayudar acá lejos de ella las
llamas también devoraron la casa de
Marilyn que nos muestra la arquitectura
emocional de las cenizas de su hogar
y detrás estaba
la casa con salida todo independiente
pero compartíamos esta parte que en la
cocina no estaba Cuando ocurrió el fuego
y le costó asimilar que la casa que
había heredado de sus padres ya no
estaba más esa noche necesito
tranquilizantes para dormir No yo amo
mucho este lugar y esto que nos pasó no
lo esperábamos nosotros Nunca pensamos
yo pensé el campo se nos puede quemar
pero la casa nunca pensé que se iba a
quemar esposo Jorge que presenció como
su casa ardía Sin poder salvarla tiene
ese momento grabado en su memoria
no era una un palacio pero era algo que
habíamos construido con esfuerzo con
dedicación palo pal y quedarse sin nada
Así de la noche a la mañana
la resiliencia chilena en una tierra
acostumbrada a levantarse frente a las
catástrofes se abre paso Marilyn Jorge
Nancy y Roberto comienzan a planear poco
a poco Cómo ponerse en pie de